it used to be that the white
supremacists would say that white people
are superior and now the shoot gets on
the other foot and say it says that
marginalized communities are the ones
that ought to be given advantages and I
think neither of those is compatible
with you know with true liberalism
[Music]
hello and welcome to martial matters
with me Winston Marshall for The
Spectator today I'm in Oslo and I have
the privilege of being joined by
political scientists senior fellow at
Stanford University and author of
amongst other books identity liberalism
and its discontents the origins of
political order and the famous 1992 book
the end of history in the last man so
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with us well thanks for having me
forgive me if this is uh potentially uh
tedious questions I imagine you might be
asked this a lot but I just for for
listeners and viewers who might need
refreshing on your work I I wondered if
we could if I could take you back 34
years to your essay the end of history
in which you argued
what we may be witness witnessing is not
just the end of the Cold War or the
passing of a particular period of
post-war history but the end of history
as such that is the end point of
Mankind's ideological Evolution and the
universalization of Western liberal
democracy as the final form of human
government but as I said in your speech
yesterday
you were examining the fall of democracy
and uh it's and um the failure of
liberalism so I wondered how is your
thinking changed over the last 34 years
since you wrote that well you know what
we've had in the last uh 17 years or so
is not the fall of democracy but we've
had setbacks uh you know the process of
the development of democratic
institutions is never a linear uh
process and
um you know the end of History really uh
was a question of what direction is uh
historical progress moving in the
modernization process uh so yeah we've
not done well uh democracy has had a lot
of setbacks there are now some big
authoritarian Alternatives like Russia
and China uh setbacks and individual
places that we thought had been making a
transition to democracy Myanmar Tunisia
and so forth but you know in terms of
the broader historical question you know
the one that I was the most interested
in in writing that Essa in that book is
is there a superior form of of Human
Social organization the way the marxists
believe that the end of History would be
communism you know that this was a final
stage that would be superior to what
they called Bourgeois
democracy tied to a capitalist system
and you know my argument was there is no
clear you know higher stage that we're
moving to and I think that remains the
case but certainly we're in a period of
democratic setback right now so uh so
you see do I write an understanding it's
still a hegelian idea that there is a
concept of progress through history yeah
I mean you know I think that I I what I
generally say to people that die that
there is a progress I say well maybe you
should try living for a while in
Guatemala or the Democratic Republic of
Congo I don't want to pick those
countries out particularly in in an
insulting way but you know generally
speaking people flee that kind of
country to go live in Norway or you know
the United States or some You Know Rich
democracy and I think that you know
indicates the fact that there has in
fact been progress if you are a rich
industrialized stable peaceful democracy
there are a lot of advantages over
living in a poor you know unstable
corrupt uh uh place I would maybe push
back on the idea that uh if we liberal
democracy is the highest you're yet to
see a a a political Theory higher than
that but if people are voting against
liberalism as they are and and it seems
that uh it's there's another wave of it
in Germany for example the alternative
for Deutschland is a right-wing party uh
is is now at 19 of the polls
um uh we see conservative leaders or ban
Maloney and we've seen perceptive
leaders across the West uh right Rising
the post it wouldn't that suggest that
many people voters don't agree that
liberalism or liberal democracy is that
or liberalism specifically maybe first
we will do all that is the highest form
and actually they think that they've
been let down by liberalism well I think
that uh you know and I actually
developed this at some length in the
book version of that end of history
essay there's a problem with uh you know
peaceful stable liberal democracy
because people don't simply live for
material comfort and security they have
aspirations and they have pride and they
have a sense of justice and they
oftentimes you know in the problem with
liberalism is that it's based on a kind
of universal recognition of your human
dignity that you share with every other
human being on the planet but you know
there are times when that's not enough
for people and so they want to say well
I I'm not just a human being not just a
generic human being I'm a Hungarian and
I need to you know preserve my Hungarian
culture whatever you know you conceive
of that being or you know in the case of
India which was really born a liberal
Republic
you now have people voting for The BJP
and this form of Hindu nationalism which
I think is you know a more restricted
understanding of you know what holds
India together and one that is
potentially very dangerous uh because
you know there are a lot of people
living in India that aren't Hindu and I
think you know could be the root of a
lot of violence and so I think that you
know that was the origin of liberalism
in the first place liberalism was born
out of the European Wars of religion
following the Reformation when
Protestants were killing Catholics and
vice versa for 150 years and there's
this recognition by early liberal
thinkers that you had to lower the
horizons of politics and focus on just
respect for life itself and not the good
life as defined by a particular you know
religious view of of human final ends
and you know it's something that is in
constant tension with people's desire to
live in societies that are defined by
much narrower understanding things of
what the good or what the good life are
and I think you're now seeing you know
kind of resurgence of that there's
something that you actually I think what
we're what you're getting at is the the
the can nationalism and liberalism be
reconciled because that seems to be the
the fault line a little bit and that is
something that you wrote about in the
original essay and whether nationalism
and also religion but we'll hopefully we
can get to that uh that they might be
ideological competitors to liberalism do
you think that liberalism and
nationalism can be reconciled oh sure
they can be reconciled I have actually
a whole part of my last book liberalism
and its discontents devoted to the
question of national identity because I
don't think you can have a political
order of any sort unless you have a
common understanding of your national
identity
um the trick for liberalism is that it
has to be a liberal identity that is to
say it's an identity that is accessible
to all of the diverse people that may
actually be living in your Society
meaning that it can't be based really on
a fixed characteristic like ethnicity or
race or gender you know it really does
need to be inclusive of you know the
actual population that that lives in
your Society but you know if it meets
those criteria yeah people do need a
sense of you know an insight and outside
what defines citizenship you know what
core values people share and if it's a
liberal Society those values ought to be
liberal so that you know the virtue of
Tolerance ought to be something that is
you know key to the National
understanding of a liberal Republic and
this is this is something I've heard you
speak about the grounding it in a
greater idea nationalism can't be ground
grounded in uh very few people disagree
here in an ethno National let's say 20
Century all too clearly and you've also
I've heard you argue that neither can it
be grounded in a religious identity and
it needs to be an idea that that
supersedes those
I but I would struggle to find an idea
that could supersede them even
liberalism so let me take American
listening for example uh the the
foundational uh one of the foundational
texts is the um the Declaration of
Independence and that Jefferson wrote we
hold these truths to be self-evident
that all men are created equal that they
are endowed by their creator of certain
unalienable rights that's one of the
foundations of liberal uh thought but it
is grounded in religion ultimately that
is a metaphysical presupposition well
but it's one
um
so you're right I mean people do
actually have to believe in Liberal
values to maintain a liberal Republic
they can't believe in non-liberal values
right uh so yes there there is a
restriction in that sense that's true
but that's all I'm saying is that you
know you have to have this fundamental
belief that people want to live in a
liberal society that is defined by
tolerance for you know people that
disagree with you about certain
fundamental questions but that you're
going to respect those differences and
not carry them into the political sphere
and certainly not allow that to lead to
violence uh I think that's really the
condition what idea do you think that
could bind a nation that is well the
idea of freedom I mean look I'm here at
the Oslo Freedom Forum I think that uh
you know everybody at that Forum has
lived under an authoritarian regime that
restricts your ability to speak your
ability to move around your ability to
travel your ability to engage in kind of
ordinary economic activity I mean all of
these things and I think people you know
believe that their dignity as human
beings is based on their uh ability to
make those kinds of choices for
themselves without the government saying
you have to do this and you have to do
that I think people really like that and
that is a kind of uh you know they may
not agree on
the liberal solution necessarily but
they certainly don't like these
restrictive regimes that really limit
their Liberty so I think you know there
is something in common now you know uh
liberalism by itself does tend to be a
rather thin set of common values and so
it usually has to be combined with other
cultural features you know it could be
Sports it could be food language is
extremely important it could be Sports
yeah how would that work well there's a
great example of this in in from
Hollywood uh you know the film Invictus
so this was the Rugby World Cup in 1996
when South Africa had just made its
transition from uh apartheid and in the
movie you know the whites in South
Africa and their team the springboks uh
you know were in a way pitted against
the blacks who played soccer and now
Mandela has had this understanding that
if you're really going to have this
rainbow Nation things like you know
rooting for the same sports team is very
important and so he took it upon himself
to you know there was they were the
sponsor of the World Cup and he took it
on himself to convince his fellow black
South Africans to root for the
springboks and of course the springboks
happened to win that year which was a
very convenient thing but you know it's
an example about uh you know no no thick
national identity is simply going to be
built around sports but it's one of
those things that contributes to you
know a sense of commonality if you think
about the United States you know the a
game of baseball was invented in the
1870s precisely to try to overcome the
uh division you know this serious
Division and bitterness that had been
created by the Civil War that it
happened just a couple of decades
earlier and you know in fact for many
generations after that baseball became
one of the uh defining characteristics
of what it meant to be an American mind
you know you watch these World War II
movies and they think there's a Nazi spy
how do you find out whether he's a real
American you say who won the 1943 World
Series you know if you can't answer that
you're not an American
unfortunately you know I think we've
kind of gone backwards in our uh sense
of a common American national identity
and so I think actually most American
kids aren't going to be able to answer
that equivalent question asked in you
know in 2023 but you know that's
important in in the case of French
Republican post-revolution national
identity language is extremely important
right then again language is one of
those things that is accessible so if
you're Leopold song or you're a black
Senegalese poet but you write in French
then you know the French Republic will
take you into the academy Frances and
you know you are considered a full
French citizen so that's that's what
liberal identity I think is built around
those things certainly bind and as an
Englishman I can tell you when England
play the football it's one of the only
times that it's to unite the whole
country and and romantic is that story
of South Africa and very real as it was
as a unifying force it wasn't so much
the the foundation uh Stone on which a
unified Nation could be built but rather
a manifestation of wouldn't it Mandela's
ideas of what the South African nation
could be and it was him at the core oh
yeah but let's philosophy but look I
mean National identities aren't just
lying around they're not biological
facts you know they're created they're
and that's why you need leadership uh
you know there's a there's two things
that have to happen if you have a viable
political order you have to have State
Building which means the building of the
kind of visible formal institutions you
know the Army the police the bureaucracy
the finance ministry these sorts of
things but you also need the sense of
common shared narratives and stories
that you tell about you know your
society and that's where leaders are
extremely important because and
sometimes the leaders aren't even
political leaders they can be poets they
can be filmmakers they can be musicians
uh you know and all of those I think
contribute to a people having a single
sense of what it means to be you know a
member of their National community and
that is having a religion the ultimate
sort of Mythos to under the ultimate
yeah so that's I mean religion so that's
fine that's the that's the um that's the
difference between a liberal and an ill
liberal order because if you're living
in a country that has big religious
divisions in it if you pick a single one
of those Division I mean even you know
even in the case of protestantism uh
there's so many sects within
protestantism that you're still not
going to get National Unity you know
just within that one you know branch of
Christianity and that's why religion has
always been very problematic that's why
you know what Modi is trying to
accomplish in India right now is
extremely uh problematic because you
know there's 200 million Muslims living
in India that aren't part of his
understanding of what it means to be an
Indian and in fact he's disenfranchising
a lot of them
well that would be a problem but uh if
because it's it's a majority group with
the Hindus who are not tolerant of the
minority group but if if you let's say
take America although and going back to
protestantism uh sure there were
disparate groups of Protestants and and
different uh different churches but they
were under the umbrella so The
ecumenical umbrella of Christianity and
um although it was a liberal Society it
was a tolerant Christianity but they
were the majority and there was that on
which they could build a nation and a
tolerant majority is that the liberal
dream
well I think a tolerant majority
certainly is the liberal dream I think
that there are important Christian Roots
you know to democracy itself I mean the
belief in the universality of Human
Rights you know or the liberal
acceptance of the equal Dignity of all
people ultimately if you trace it back
historically does have Roots I think in
Christian universalism so historically
that's a fact but it doesn't mean that
you uh then need to take a particular
strong form of Christian identity uh as
you know the dominant one in your
Society because there simply won't be I
mean you know you have
you have a bunch of these new uh
right-wing conservative intellectuals
you know Catholic integralists like
Adrian vermeul this professor at Harvard
or uh Patrick Dineen as professor at
Notre Dame has just written a book about
post-liberalism and they basically want
to go back to some kind of conservative
Catholicism as The Binding religion in
the United States you know it's totally
ridiculous they're getting into the
Theocratic yeah I mean it's ridiculous
you cannot possibly do that in a society
that is as diverse uh you know even if a
majority have a Christian cultural
background there's a lot of secular
Christians in the world and the same
problem in Israel right now you know
that
maybe apart from the
Arab minority most Israelis are are
Jewish but a lot of them are secular
Jews and so you know having a particular
religious interpretation of Judaism as
their national identity just isn't going
to work in that kind of a society with
your nation no matter your country
America these post-liberals that you've
mentioned and the the Catholic and
Technical integralists they are
responding to a failure of liberalism
post-liberalism well or their their
claim they claim yeah they claim that
there's been a failure of liberalism uh
so where do the post-liberals get it
wrong well you know I debated Patrick
Dineen uh last year about this where he
claimed that there's a liberal tyranny
you know this uh this is a so-called
woke uh dominance of American culture
and it's just a wild exaggeration you
know of yeah I think that contemporary
America is one of the freest societies
that's ever lived politically you know
he and his conservative friends can
complain about Joe Biden all they want
they can demonstrate they can have their
own religious community nobody's
stopping them from doing that the the
the only areas where you get this kind
of uniformity of liberal thought or on a
restricted set of basically civil rights
issues having to do with race ethnicity
gender sexual orientation and that
dominance is true only in certain kind
of elite spaces like universities you
know Hollywood the Arts and so forth and
there you know I think there is a there
is a bit of a problem because a lot of
you know Progressive identity politics
tends to get pretty intolerant and
that's the you know that's a left-wing
threat to uh to liberalism but you know
Patrick Dineen then goes from that to
saying we live in a total tyranny you
know I mean no difference between us and
China or Russia and it's just it's
absurd you know it's just absurd do you
think um in America there is a problem
of of national Unity so it might not be
an oppressive State as you as you always
but
for I'm watching from afar from my uh
through my phone in in London looking
America only this week I saw uh given
that it's pride month we had uh um some
transgenders on the White House lawn
taking their tops off and wiggling their
breasts uh with the with the pride flag
draped from from the White House and
that obviously gets a huge reaction from
Patriots American Patriots so it seems
and of course I appreciate that social
media will make divisions seem well
pronounced but is your country a divided
country and and
are you worried about its its future
well it's certainly divided uh you know
that transgender issue is kind of the
tip of the sphere of you know a number
of cultural divisions that have appeared
and uh you know they play off of each
other because uh you know the people
taking their tops off the transgender
people taking their tops off really set
off a you know a countervailing reaction
on the right and uh it closes the space
for people that have a you know more
moderate view of you know these kinds of
you know sexual identity uh issues and
they make it actually hard to talk about
you know uh those things so that is a
problem I think they're actually you
know deeper cleavages that are Regional
that have to do with occupation you know
the single biggest division which by the
way is not unique to the United States
it's it's true of almost every country
that's got a populist movement is this
fundamental social division between more
educated people that live in big urban
areas and less educated people living in
smaller towns and cities and you know in
the countryside and there's a very
strong correlation between you know that
kind of residence and your cultural
views and then who you're going to vote
for in an election right so in Poland
you know in Warsaw people are very
liberal and uh pro-eu and you know they
have their pride weeks and so forth and
you know in the countryside you get much
more conservative religious people and
that's really kind of the base of the
piece the law and Justice party that's
that's been running Poland and that's a
that's a cleavage that's going through
quite a lot of countries right now
how do you see that cleavage playing out
uh where can just time back to the
earlier conversation was it West where's
the uniting myth to bring together the
say the cosmopolitans of the Cities yeah
well it's the business of the of the
countryside well it's hard uh it's hard
to know and I think probably every
country is going to have a different
path out I mean for example Britain I
think you have that same division but
it's it's actually a much milder form
than the one in the United States you
know as I understand it poll data that
suggests that actually support for
immigration in Britain has actually gone
up since brexit uh and that has
immigration yeah immigration right but
it's simply not the kind of neuralgic
problem that's driving people into every
deeper you know polarization whereas
that kind of thing is happening uh in
the United States I think that the way
that it ends is you know there are
several ones you could have simply a
demographic shift I mean because if you
look at the real base for example of
trump supporters they're all older
voters you know they're people that are
50 60 you know on up and uh there's some
evidence that the coming Generations you
know they start out much more to the
left and it's very possible that
there'll be a kind of uh you know not
just it's not just a cohort effect but
it's it's well it is a cohort effect
that they will continue to be more
liberal as they get older meaning that
social attitudes on some of these
cultural questions will simply shift and
that's one possibility the other
possibility is that since populist
voters are a minority in virtually every
country where they exist they will
simply start to lose elections Donald
Trump already lost three in a row and I
think if he loses again 2024 by the
popular vote you mean yeah by the
popular vote if he loses again in 2024 a
lot of Republicans are just gonna
you know finally accept the obvious
which is this is not the route to
gaining power in the United States you
know that this form of grievance-filled
politics is just not working
when you use the term populism is that
is that how you define it a sort of
extreme right-wing grievance field of
politics well it's uh that's kind of the
manifestation of it a lot of it really
has to do with a you know deep distrust
of Elites and this belief that there's a
kind of an elite conspiracy taking place
that uh where the you know it's the red
pill phenomenon that you know they've
taken the red pill and they realize that
they've been taking the blue pill and
they thought that their institutions
were Democratic and legitimate but they
suddenly realized that no in fact it's
being run by this you know this evil Mr
Anderson right okay let's say there's a
conspiratorial
extremist to to that group who do think
of such sort of Evil Lizard people
controlling things and but it's not
unfair to say there there are an elite
set of people a class of people with a
world view fundamentally different from
the working classes of America say they
live in the Hamptons whereas A working
class you know the farmers of Kentucky
and and and so it's not completely
unfair to us oh no it's not completely
to to their worldview no there's there's
um if you interpreted this in
traditional class terms they've got a
real problem right because globalization
really did uh damage the incomes and job
opportunities of a lot of working class
especially working class you know white
people and so that is something that
could be remedied by you know the
appropriate political and social
policies but what's bizarre you know in
a way about American politics over the
last generation is that people's
economic self-interests have become
attached from their political
views and they're much more concerned
about these kinds of cultural questions
than they are you know if if they were
really worried about you know losing
their jobs and losing their social
standing they should be all in favor of
Obamacare you know because then they
won't lose their health insurance as
well but they're all voting against
Obamacare and they've been persuaded to
because really the politics has become
sort of tribalized where you know even
if your team is doing things that hurt
your economic self-interest you're going
to keep you know you're going to keep
rooting for it because you've been
convinced that the other side is evil
that's what political scientists refer
to as effective polarization where
you're not just disagreeing over policy
issues you actually hate the other side
and you know think that their winning is
going to mean you're losing and those
sort of thing that's happening on both
sides though uh well it's it's more
prominent I think on the right than on
the left but the two sides definitely
set each other off you know the people
on the left can say well these people
are just a bunch of racists and see
xenophobic bigots and you know we don't
have to listen to them and that means
that they don't actually have to accept
the fact that you know there's a real
economic problem that's been created by
big corporations moving their jobs you
know to Asia well you you mentioned
globalization and uh
you're saying and and I noticed in your
speech yesterday you were careful to
delineate yourself as a classical
Liberal Liberal rather than a neoliberal
and and without neoliberalism is that
not sort of national liberalism is that
no no I mean in terms of economic policy
it just means rewinding the clock to you
know the period before the 1980s when
you had the Chicago school and Ronald
Reagan and Margaret Thatcher you know
taking this interpretation this critique
of the role of the state in the economy
and carrying that to extremes that's
really the problem uh that there is a
demonization of the state which led to
for example deregulation of the
financial sector that then led directly
to the financial crisis in 2008 and I
think that you can
you know believe in capitalism and
property rights and all those good
things and still have a state that
regulates you know the behavior of these
big Banks there's you know we used to do
it for decades and you know we had much
more financial stability so I think
actually rewinding the neoliberal
economic agenda is one of the easiest
things to do and in fact Biden has
already accomplished most of that what
about the the sort of global
globalization aspect of neoliberal yeah
well that uh is harder to unwind uh
what's being Unwound right now is
actually the Strategic interaction with
China because I think that many people
have realized that we become dependent
on China for stuff that is militarily
important you know like semiconductors
Rare Earth you know many of the kind of
leading technologies that will be
important not just for the economy but
you know in terms of strategic
competition and so that part is being
decoupled but really you know
U.S Europe and China are so
interdependent that it's very hard to
imagine you know we're going to stop
selling soybeans to China or things like
that so in in that context then what is
the future of liberalism
well I mean liberalism will do just fine
I mean in the economic so what I was
saying is in the sphere of Economic
Policy it's very easy to unwind
neoliberalism right you just re-inject
the state you start regulating markets
again uh you pay more attention to
social protections you know to people
that are hurt by the fluctuations of you
know completely free markets and that's
something that I think is underway in
virtually every Advanced country so that
part of it is is fine it's a little bit
harder to unwind the kind of progressive
identity politics that has come to you
know Define the left which is also a
threat to liberalism because a lot of it
becomes very intolerant and well it
isn't liberal I would argue it isn't
liberal and it also denies a fundamental
premise about you know the universal
equality of human beings because it says
well actually you know it used to be
that the white supremacists would say
that white people are superior and now
you know the shoot gets on the other
foot and say it says that marginalized
communities are the ones that ought to
be given advantages and uh and I think
neither of those is compatible with you
know with true liberalism
it sounds like uh you're you're
defending the sort of Center the old
Center left uh yeah well sure I mean I
think the um that basic Center left you
know Social Democratic formula was
really what guaranteed the stability of
democracy after 1945 especially in
Europe but also in the United States I
mean the New Deal was the American
Acceptance of the need for a extensive
welfare state and I think every modern
democracy adopted some form of it you
know they went overboard with it in
terms of its long-term fiscal
sustainability and so they had to cut
back and modify but yeah it's a winning
formula and I think it continued
continue to be a winning formula in the
future well on that positive note uh
Francis thank you so much for speaking
with me and I'm sure business would have
loved it so okay thanks so much thank
you
[Music]
thank you